so we're given this expression is the
Taylor series about zero for which of
the following functions and they give us
some choices here so let's just think a
little bit about this series that they
gave us so if we were to expand it out
let's see when n is equal to 0 would be
negative 1 to the 0 power which is 1
times X to 0 which is 1 over 0 factorial
which is 1 so it'll be 1 plus and then
when n is 1 well then this is going to
be negative so it's going to be minus
and then X to the first over 1 factorial
over well I could just write that as X
right over here and then when n is to
the negative negative 1 squared that's
going to be positive x squared over 2
and that's going to be minus X to the
third over 3 factorial and then it's
going to be plus and I can keep going
you've seen this before X to the fourth
over 4 factorial it's gonna keep going -
plus it's going to keep alternating on
and on and on now our general form for
our Taylor series about 0 which we could
also call them Maclaurin series would be
our general form would be f of 0 plus F
prime of 0 times X plus F prime prime of
0 times x squared over 2 plus the third
derivative at 0 times X to the third
over 3 factorial plus the fourth
derivative if you get the idea evaluated
at 0 times X to the fourth over 4
factorial and we would just go on and on
and on now to figure out which function
in order for this in order what I wrote
in blue to be the mcclure or to be the
Taylor series about zero room in order
to be the Maclaurin series and that
means that that means that F of 0 needs
to be equal to 1 it means that F prime
of 0 actually let me write this down it
means that F of 0 needs to be equal to 1
f of 0
is equal to 1 it means that F prime of 0
needs to be the coefficient on the X
here which is negative 1
now we could keep going it means that it
means that the second derivative at 0
well that's going to be the coefficient
on this x squared over 2 so that's got
to be equal to 1 and you see the general
idea the third derivative at 0 is equal
to negative 1 it's the coefficient on
the X third x to the third over 3
factorial which is negative 1 right over
here and so just using this information
can we figure out which of these it is
so you could do a little bit of
deductive reasoning here for let's all
evaluate all of these functions at 0 and
see which of these are 1 so sine of 0
well that's 0 just by looking at this
first constraint sine of 0 isn't 1 we
can rule that out cosine of 0 is 1 so
that's still in the running
e to the 0 is 1 e to the 0 is 1 and then
the natural log of 1 plus 0 that's the
natural log of 1 which is a 0 so that's
out of the running so just from that
first constraint knowing that F of 0 is
equal to 1 were able to rule out two of
the choices then knowing that the first
derivative evaluated at 0 is going to be
negative 1 well what's the first
derivative of cosine of X what's
negative sine of X if we evaluate that
at 0 we're not going to get negative 1
we're going to get 0 so we can rule this
out now the first derivative of e to the
X is e to the X if we evaluate that at 0
we're gonna get 1 not negative 1 so we
can rule that out and so not even
looking at anything else we have a
pretty good sense that D is probably our
answer but we could check the first
derivative here F prime of X here is
going to be negative e to the negative x
so f prime of 0 is going to be is going
to be negative e to the 0 or negative 1
so it meets that one and if we if you
were curious you could keep going and
see that see that it meets all the other
constraints but choice D is the only one
that meets even the first two
constraints for the function at 0 and
the first derivative at
zero